from Los Angeles California now
celebrating its bicentennial year and
the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences is proud to present the 53rd
annual Academy Awards we're in the plaza
the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion of the
Music Center in Los Angeles California
for Oscars 53rd annual show these
most glamorous figures for tonight's
international event
including Diana Scarlett the nominee is
performance in inside mood
they accomplished multi-talented petros
dinar
tonight show this is Loretta Lynn her
life was portrayed by [ __ ] Spacek in
Coal Miner's Daughter sissy's received
an Oscar nomination for the role
injectors will present the best
documentary award together
Richard Chamberlain
join Margot Kidder
live-action short film
this is the beautiful sigourney week you
present the Oscar in the best costume
category
the hugely talented Robert Duvall a Best
Actor nominee for his performance in the
Great Santini a Best Supporting Actress
candidate for her word in private
Benjamin Eileen Brennan
this is one of Hollywood's most solid
and respected professionals in this
Steiger and here are the singing and
acting co-stars of the winds lammers
Diana Ross and Hansen Michael Jackson
one of the Best Supporting Actress
nominee is Mary Steenburgen she's the
star of Melvin and Howard the Best
Supporting Actor candidate for his
performance in ordinary people John Hurt
and Timothy Hutton son of the late Jim
Hutton and also an Oscar nominee for
Best Supporting Actor in ordinary people
in a very French motion picture
the popular Mary Tyler Moore who
received her first Oscar nominee in this
year's balloting for her role in
ordinary people
and this is respected actor Billy Dee
Williams so presenter on this evenings
program in the best sound can ago
previous Oscar winner
again this year in the Best Actress
category for resurrect
Peter O'Toole is the MA
David s best doctor for
his sixth Oscar nomination
and the fabulous dolly parton nominated
in the best song category for her
composition nine-to-five
the 53rd annual Academy Awards story
Rep Jim Chamberlain George Cukor
Angie Dickinson Leslie and down
Sally Field
Dustin Hoffman
[ __ ] kidder
Jack Lemmon Henry Mancini Steve Martin
Mary Tyler Moore Willie Nelson the
Nicholas brothers
luciano pavarotti Bernadette Peters
Richard Pryor Robert Redford
Ramos shipper
Jane Seymour rookie
[ __ ] Spacek
can Vito
Sigourney Weaver
Vicki Williams
ceremonies John person
ladies and gentlemen Johnny Carson
thank you
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
I'm sure that all of you here and most
of you watching tonight understand why
we delayed this program for 24 hours
because of the incredible events of
yesterday that old adage the show must
go on seemed relatively unimportant the
Academy ABC television and all of us
connected with a show thought because of
the uncertain outcome as of this time
yesterday it would have been
inappropriate to stage a celebration but
the news today is very good as you know
the president is in excellent condition
at last reports he's been conducting
business
and he is uh and he happened to be in
very good spirits after all you must
remember this is a man who yesterday
while he was in the hospital unable to
speak wrote on a sheet of paper all
things considered I'd rather be in
Philadelphia
so tonight the show does go on now two
weeks ago
President Reagan videotaped an opening
greeting for this occasion we were in
contact with the White House about two
hours ago and it was the president's
expressed wishes that we use that
introduction and I might add you might
like to know that he also asked for
television sat in his room so he could
view this program tonight I was
actually the president was in such good
form today I was very tempted to call
him and ask him if he had any more of
those one-liners that I could use so it
is especially pleasing tonight ladies
and gentlemen to be able to say here is
the President of the United States
my fellow Americans eagerly awaiting the
presentation of the 53rd annual Academy
Awards it surely no state secret that
Nancy and I share your interest in the
results of this year's balloting we're
not alone the miracle of American
technology links us with millions of
moviegoers around the world it's the
motion picture that shows us all not
only how we look and sound but more
important how we feel when it achieves
its most noble intent film reveals the
people everywhere share common dreams
and emotions tonight I applaud all who
create make distribute exhibit and
attend movies I salute the Academy for
the influence its work has on the
world's most enduring art form film is
forever I've been trapped in some film
forever myself and is a former member of
the Academy I ask you now to join Nancy
and me in enjoying this year's
ceremonies